se é um apaixonado por tecnologia e
teorias comportamentais empresário atua
na área tecnológica está novas ideias e
tendências Anselmo e longe gostaria de
inverter a ideia de que nosso futuro
depende de outras pessoas
Boa tarde a todos
eu queria dizer para vocês que estou
muito feliz de poder ter saído do Brasil
ontem vocês vão ver com meu português é
um pouco diferente é e agradecer também
a Cristina pelo convite ao Marco o
Ricardo flores e claro minha esposa pela
força que me deram para estar aqui hoje
eu demorei um pouco aceitar o convite
Porque para mim é muito difícil falar
sobre mim mesmo eu acho que é algo um
Pouquinho complicado mas quando eu vi o
tema do evento eu achei que eu não
poderia negar esse convite porque
inverter algo que eu venho tentando
fazer durante toda a vida e acho que
muito mais do que inverter eu venho
tentando subverter as coisas veio
tentando criar um pouco de confusão no
sistema e mudar um pouco da ordem das
coisas
a a a minha história começou muito cedo
meus pais são bastante humilde sair
então importante de uma família bastante
humilde a meus meu pai telefonista e
claro Meu Grande Herói portanto minha
perspectiva de futuro meu primeiro
grande sonho foi seguir a carreira do
meu pai e você também um camionista ao
passar do tempo os meus sonhos foram
crescendo um pouquinho eu comecei como
toda criança que deve sonhar EA gente
deve estimular sempre isso nos nas
crianças sonhar é passei a ter sonhos
como toda criança que ele sempre jogador
de futebol durante uma fase que está
nadador profissional piloto de caça que
isso tem um bom emprego queria ter uma
boa casa uma linda família e comecei a
perceber que um esse meu passado de uma
família humilde haveria assim com
e a lutar para conseguir as coisas que
eu tanto sonhava e foi quando eu comecei
a me perguntar sim mas como eu posso
inverter a minha história a
e logo aos 15 anos eu tive uma ideia
falei bom para começar a para estudar em
uma boa escola eu preciso pagar a escola
mas como então eu decidi aceitar um
emprego fui trabalhar em uma lavanderia
não poderia querer trabalhar em muita
coisa diferente já que não tinha a
formação ainda era muito novo então eu
saio todo dia de casa 5 horas da manhã
para ir para essa Lavanderia sairá
correndo a 5 horas da tarde ainda meio
Azul das causas de gambá
eu ia para escola chegava lá um pouco
pintado continuei lutando pelos meus
sonhos e conseguir um estágio numa
companhia de Telecomunicações
E logo na primeira semana aconteceu uma
coisa que mudou totalmente a minha vida
eu fui convidado para assistir uma
palestra de motivacional e tomei
conhecimento de algo que realmente me
ajudou muito a seguir os meus sonhos e a
trabalhar aprende algo realmente muito
importante sobre trabalhar com amor
e eu fiquei sabendo dessa palestra que
eu iria passar as 10 melhores horas da
minha vida durante os 45 melhores anos
dela trabalhando portanto se eu não
trabalhasse com a moça eu me dedicasse
gostasse realmente muito do que eu iria
fazer eu já estava morto portanto eu
resolvi mudar a minha trajetória e
realmente trabalhar somente com coisas
que eu me sinta apaixonado que eu saia
de casa todos os dias com aquela
sensação do de uma amor quando aquela
sensação que a gente encontra a pessoa
que a gente ama então decidi dali em
diante trabalhar realmente sempre com
muito amor
o que foi que me deu muita motivação
para seguir crescendo e seguir buscando
os meus sonhos e mais uma vez eu comecei
a me perguntar como que eu poderia
chegar nesses meus sonhos que eram cada
vez maiores como vivemos na sociedade da
informação eu achei não sei por que
motivo que Leto estudar muito fosse
fazer alguma diferença na minha vida
então eu aproveitava as três horas que
eu passava no Autocarro todos os dias do
meu trabalho até é da minha casa até o
meu trabalho lembro eu tinha três horas
de tempo livre todos os dias e ao invés
de lamentar o fato de ter que todo dia
estar em um ônibus cheio esse momento
para ler e Lia cerca de continuo lendo
mais linda então naquela época cerca de
dez revistas dois livros todos os meses
já que tinha tanto tempo ocioso
o ipe continuei me permitindo fazer
sempre coisas diferentes
eu continuei passando de por vários
empregos e continue progredindo até aqui
sempre trabalhando com bastante amor né
porque eu acho que é uma coisa que que
realmente ajudou muito isso me permitiu
por exemplo é trabalhar a noite inteira
muitas vezes sem ganhar nada somente
para poder estar havendo bons
profissionais fazendo seu trabalho mais
uma vez eu achava que aquilo ia me
ajudar em algum momento que não ia ser
um tempo a sua à toa
hoje aos 22 anos eu já tinha eu já
estava em uma posição bastante
confortável eu já eu era gerente de
tecnologia de uma empresa foi uma fase
bastante importante da minha vida porque
nasceu também minha primeira filha Sara
que hoje tem 11 anos de idade
bom e comecei a ver que alguma coisa
estava errado eu não saía mais de casa
de amor que eu tinha com toda aquela
motivação eu tava um pouco cansado
daquele modelo tradicional que as
empresas eram muito rígidas cheia de ar
Kia cheia de certezas cheia de coisas
que não podiam ser mudadas e Aquilo
tinha me cansado um pouco bom então eu
comecei a pensar a pensar e falei eu
acho que está na hora de mudar de novo
acho que tá na hora de buscar coisas
novas Até mesmo porque os meus sonhos
tinham crescido um pouco eu já não
queria mais ter um carro novo eu passo
eu queria ter um avião
Oi e aí o que eu vou fazer bom então
decidir realmente inverter de novo
sistema muito mais do que isso subverter
e comecei a dividir os meus sonhos Foi
quanto encontrei uma pessoa que
trabalhava comigo na outra empresa o
Rogério salume que hoje é o meu sócio um
passou a ser um grande irmão ao longo da
minha vida e durante a uma hora de voo
que nós tivemos nós dividimos os sonhos
um com o outro e percebemos que o nosso
sonho era muito parecido tinha muita
coisa em comum uma hora depois nós
pousamos
e a gente não sabia muito bem ainda o
que que a gente queria fazer a gente só
sabia que a gente queria mudar o sistema
o que a gente ainda não tinha muita
certeza
e a gente ainda tava ali numa fase bem
complicada bom foi quando o vinho
apareceu na vida da gente
é tudo aquilo que a gente fazia desde
então com muito amor a gente passou a
fazer ainda mais com amor que a gente
tinha certeza que a gente tinha
descoberto algo que fazia a gente
acordar todos os dias com muita
disposição com muito amor e com muito
mais vontade
e a gente ainda não tinha nem começado
um negócio mas o nosso sonho já era
maior negócio de vinhos do mundo
e era um sonho um pouco modesto mas eram
a gente achava que se ajudar a gente a
chegar lá
é bom abrimos um negócio o primeiro site
de venda de vinhos online do Brasil e
dois anos depois Três anos depois o
negócio não deu certo
e foi uma fase muito dura porque todo
aquele sonho toda toda aquela energia ia
naquele momento ficou perdida
o Márcio mais uma vez ao invés de nos
lamentarmos por isso o sonho ainda
estava presente e esse sonho nos fez
levantar no mesmo dia e comer pedir esse
sonho novamente com outras pessoas
há seis meses depois estávamos lançando
um novo site de venda de vinhos da
wine.com.br novas pessoas acreditaram
nesse sonho com a gente os nossos
investidores
o título do foi muito bem a empresa
começou a crescer Hoje Somos o 2º maior
site de vinhos do mundo e tudo ia muito
bem tudo muito feliz até que um ano
depois aconteceu uma coisa que mudou é
tu mudou muito a minha vida porque eu
sofri um acidente junto para minha
esposa e quase morremos e três meses na
cama é sem saber se ia poder voltar a
andar Cia poder voltar correr atrás dos
sonhos É mas isso eu comecei a buscar o
que que a vida tinha para me mostrar o
que que avisa queria me mostrar com
aquele acidente e foi realmente uma fase
de muito autoconhecimento porque tinha
tempo Ocioso de mais três meses numa
cama você tem muito tempo para pensar em
o e percebi que a morte dos aproxima
muito da gente nos aproxima com o eu
interior de uma forma magnífica
é através da minha esposa que sempre me
estimulou muito a escrever algo que até
então eu achava que era uma coisa de
mulher e escrever um diário
e é eu mais eu comecei a escrever e
passei a perceber que aquele instrumento
era algo muito menos doloroso de
conectar comigo mesmo que eu não sou uma
ter quase morrido para mim conectar
comigo e se inscrever diariamente me fez
estar mais presente saber onde eu quero
chegar como eu quero chegar
o ipe passei a buscar uma vida com muito
mais propósito entendeu tenho cupida tá
me dando oportunidade de estar aqui
ocupando o espaço nesse fininho do mundo
por quê que a vida tá me dando essa
chance então passei a perceber que um
pouco da minha do meu propósito também
era mostrar para as outras pessoas que
elas podiam Acreditar no impossível que
assim como eu tinha buscado os meus
sonhos acreditar dos meus sonhos outras
pessoas também poderiam buscar os seus
sonhos e correrá com seus sonhos
há uns anos depois eu assisti um
discurso o famoso discurso de Steve Jobs
de Stanford onde ele fala sobre
conectando os pontos e ele fala uma
coisa muito mágica que era ele tinha
visto que era impossível conectar os
pontos para frente que a gente só podia
conectar os pontos para trás e passei a
entender o quão importante foi da hora
que eu passei dentro de um autocarro
lendo o quanto foi importante ter me
permitido cada sábado cada domingo
trabalhando muitas vezes sem ganhar nada
porque eu tenho certeza que hoje eu não
poderia estar aqui se eu não tivesse
passado por tanta coisa
Oi com a licença dele eu acho que tem
uma outra coisa muito importante que é
funções eu acho que muitas vezes a gente
tem medo de dizer os nossos sonhos para
as pessoas com medo de que alguém possa
rir se vocês não conseguirem dividir os
sonhos de vocês com outras pessoas ele
nunca será forte ser apenas um sonho de
vocês portanto de vida aos sonhos e
estudem Leiam permitam-se coisas novas
porque a gente também consegue conectar
pensamentos através da leitura através
de cada experiência dessa que a gente se
permite eu cheguei à conclusão de que
temos três coisas muito importantes para
a gente conseguir ter uma vida que vale
a pena que são elas sonhar sonho mas
sonho de verdade se imagina em fazendo
aquilo que vocês sonham se Imaginem que
vocês sonham se imagina em fazendo uma
viagem dos seus sonhos
é mas também sempre pensa em no Como
como que vocês podem fazer isso o
autoconhecimento essa coisa do escrever
diariamente fazer um balanço Diário da
vida nos ajuda muito a nos conectar com
os nossos sonhos e claro nada disso é
possível sem muito sacrifício agora aqui
com uma grande diferença Bom eu acho que
ao sacrifício cada um de vocês que estar
aqui hoje está disposto ao sacrifício
sinal nenhum de vocês estariam no sábado
aqui quantos amigos de vocês não
preferiram ficar em casa hoje então eu
acho que cada um de vocês já tem essa
predisposição ao sacrifício Porém quando
a gente faz algo que a gente ama
e o sacrifício deixa de existir porque
passa a ser uma vida com muito prazer
cada uma dessas 10 horas durante os 45
melhores anos das nossas vidas que
passamos trabalhando deixa de ser um
sacrifício passa-se algo muito valioso
mas para isso lembrem-se sempre de
pensar o que faz a vida de vocês valer a
pena eu acho que é uma coisa tão
importante os meus sonhos junto com o
meu sócio Rogério continua existindo a
gente continua tendo sonhos muito
maiores das vezes do que Devíamos e
continuamos sonhando em ser o maior
negócio de vinhos do mundo
e agora nada disso seria possível se
esse sonho acho que a gente não teria
conseguido chegar tão longe se esse
sonhos não existissem portanto a
principal mensagem que eu quero deixar
para vocês aqui hoje é sonho não tenho
medo de sonhar não tenho medo de que
alguém vai rir de vocês dos sonhos e
principalmente o futuro de vocês depende
apenas de vocês de mais ninguém Muito
obrigado
E aí